Hey all, it's The Office Ladies, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
大家好，我是《办公室丽人》珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛。
And we are so excited to present to you Season 3 of How We Made Your Mother with Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
我们非常高兴向您呈现由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主演的《我们如何创造了你的母亲》第三季。
Enjoy!
享受！
Woohoo!
呜呼！
to how we made your mother, this is our first episode of season three, can you believe it, Craig?
关于我们如何创造你的母亲，这是我们第三季的第一集，你能相信吗，克雷格？
I cannot believe it.
我简直不敢相信。
It's going to, I guess we're having fun because it's going too fast.
我想我们会很开心，因为它进展得太快了。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
It's going fast.
进展很快。
I'm actually freaked out that we're already in season three.
我真的很害怕我们已经进入第三季了。
Let me ask you this, Craig Thomas, my co-host of How We Made Your Mother.
让我问你这个问题，克雷格·托马斯，我的《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的联合主持人。
Oh, hi.
哦，嗨。
What did you do on your three week summer hiatus?
你在暑假的三周时间里做了什么？
I had the shortest summer hiatus.
我度过了最短的暑假。
Yeah, and it wasn't summer, which was also weird for a summer hiatus.
是的，当时不是夏天，这对于夏天的休息来说也很奇怪。
My daughter was studying the Revolutionary War, so we went for her spring break to Philadelphia, where I saw in person the Liberty Bell for the first time.
我女儿正在研究独立战争，所以我们去费城度过她的春假，在那里我第一次亲眼看到了自由钟。
Even though we wrote a whole episode about looking at it, I had never been there in actual life.
尽管我们写了一整集关于观看它的内容，但我在现实生活中从未去过那里。
And I tweeted about this years ago, I seriously want to talk to a security guard at the Liberty Bell and see how many hymnum fans they had to tackle or I should have asked and I didn't.
几年前我在推特上谈到了这一点，我真的很想和自由钟的保安谈谈，看看他们必须对付多少赞美诗歌迷，否则我应该问，但我没有。
but then I posted a picture of me there and a lot of people then sent me their pictures of them like pretending to lick it, like sort of a Trump loy, like they're sort of licking it, they're tend to eat in front of it, and they're kind of licking it.
但后来我在那里贴了一张我的照片，然后很多人给我发了他们假装舔它的照片，就像特朗普的忠诚一样，就像他们在舔它，他们倾向于在它前面吃东西，他们在舔它。
And then I regretted that I didn't do that photo because it was like, just go back and check it out.
然后我后悔没有拍那张照片，因为它就像，回去看看。
When was, so first season was like 2005.
什么时候，第一季好像是2005年。
So you work at the Liberty Bell, you're like, you're working there.
所以你在自由钟工作，你就像在那里工作。
And all of a sudden, it's a wave of weirdos coming to the Liberty Bell and licking it, and you're like, you don't know.
突然间，有一波怪人来到自由钟前舔舐它，而你就像，你不知道。
You don't know, you've not watched how I met your mother.
你不知道，你没有看过我是如何认识你母亲的。
There's like now a dedicated guy who's like, and now you're the lick, you're the lick guy.
就像现在有一个专注的人，现在你是舔人，你是舔人。
You're the stopping people from licking it specialist.
你是阻止人们舔它的专家。
That's how much, that's how the cultural footprint that this show has left, has affected everyone.
这就是这个节目留下的文化足迹对每个人的影响。
Even if you didn't watch it.
即使你没看过。
Fans sent me many, many pictures of them pretending to lick it.
粉丝们给我发了很多很多他们假装舔它的照片。
I don't know, I would love to know if anyone knows this, if anyone really ever did lick it.
我不知道，我很想知道是否有人知道这一点，是否有人真的舔过它。
Please not a joke.
请不要开玩笑。
If you have lick the Liberty Bell or know someone like Liberty Bell.
如果您曾舔过自由钟或认识像自由钟这样的人。
Or read a local story in Philadelphia about the guy they got arrested for licking it.
或者阅读费城当地的一个故事，讲述一个因舔它而被捕的人。
And then we should probably be like, buy that guy dinner or something.
然后我们可能应该像，请那个人吃晚饭什么的。
We know that there's people who've who've done the Naked Man, which I think is illegal in most states.
我们知道有人做过“裸体男人”，我认为这在大多数州都是非法的。
I think I know.
我想我知道。
I've seen that.
我见过那个。
Yeah.
是的。
Most states.
大多数州。
Yeah.
是的。
Every state.
每个州。
Don't do the Naked Man.
别做裸男。
But, but if you want to look, don't lick the Liberty Bell.
但是，但是如果你想看，就不要舔自由钟。
Wink, wink.
眨眼，眨眼。
We can't.
我们不能。
Let us know.
让我们知道。
Let us know if you've been to Philadelphia and it'll just like Greg.
如果您去过费城，请告诉我们，那里会像格雷格一样。
but that's fantastic.
但这太棒了。
Yeah, I felt a sense of completeness that I always felt a little bit like a fraud because we did all of this whole episode and I had never been and it felt if it was good, it was good to get there and really do it.
是的，我有一种完整感，我总觉得有点像一个骗子，因为我们做了整个这一集的所有事情，而我从来没有做过，感觉如果它很好，那么到达那里并真正做到这一点就很好。
And I went to Boston and saw more of a Revolutionary War stuff because my daughter's studying that.
我去了波士顿，看到了更多关于独立战争的东西，因为我女儿正在研究那个。
And I got to go to the Cheers Bar, which is Cheers is my all time favorite said comment I'd never been there and I went there and I bought my daughter and my wife in.
我必须去干杯酒吧，这是我一直以来最喜欢的酒吧，评论说我从来没有去过那里，我去了那里，把我的女儿和妻子买了进去。
And as I talked about my love for Cheers, I started to cry slightly.
当我谈到我对干杯的热爱时，我开始微微哭泣。
And then every time we, our hotel was, I liked that so much that show meant to me.
然后每次我们，我们的酒店，我都非常喜欢这个节目对我的意义。
And then every time we would pass the cheers bar during our time in Boston, my daughter would go, is dad going to cry again now?
然后每次我们在波士顿期间经过欢呼吧时，我女儿都会说，爸爸现在又要哭了吗？
So I was getting heckled about my love of cheers.
所以我因为我对欢呼的热爱而受到质问。
She seems like she would have done well on the how I met your mother couch, rolling her eyes.
她似乎在我如何认识你母亲的沙发上表现得很好，翻白眼。
You have no idea.
你不知道。
Just.
只是。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
What did you do?
你做了什么？
What were your, what was your child?
你的是什么，你的孩子是什么？
I've been raising.
我一直在提高。
Oh, is he, is the full grown adult?
哦，他，已经成年了吗？
No, he's off to, off to Wesley and in the fall.
不，他要在秋天去韦斯利。
You really spent through that.
你真的度过了那段时间。
That was the thing.
就是这样。
I was like, I'm not gonna waste time on this.
我当时想，我不会在这上面浪费时间。
Let's get him up and running.
让我们让他启动并运行。
No, we mostly been here.
不，我们大部分时间都在这里。
I did take him to Columbus, Ohio to see my family.
我确实带他去了俄亥俄州哥伦布市看望我的家人。
Jordana's best friend had a bachelorette thing in Maine that she was at.
乔丹娜最好的朋友在缅因州举办了一场单身派对。
And I was gonna go see my family and I had to fly with our son for the first time.
我要去见我的家人，这是我第一次和儿子一起坐飞机。
Ooh, that's a really, that's a little crowder.
哦，那真的是有点拥挤。
That's a little dude to fly with.
这是一个可以一起飞行的小家伙。
Yeah, five and a half months.
是的，五个半月。
Although I was told, and this is true, they said, a man alone in an airport with a baby, you'll be treated like a king.
尽管有人告诉我，这是事实，但他们说，一个男人带着婴儿独自在机场，你会受到国王般的待遇。
It said, everyone thinks you're a hero.
它说，每个人都认为你是英雄。
Did you get that?
你明白了吗？
Did that, was that true?
是吗，那是真的吗？
100%.
100%。
Especially on the way back, for some reason, there was even more.
尤其是回来的路上，不知道为什么，更多了。
But yeah, it was- That's really funny.
但是，是的，那是——这真的很有趣。
And it was a very unfair.
这是非常不公平的。
But I met a woman who, her son was nine, I met her the weekend before at a thing, And she, her son's like a world traveler.
但我遇到了一个女人，她的儿子九岁了，我在前一个周末的一次活动中认识了她，而她，她的儿子就像一个环球旅行者。
Like they've been everywhere with this kid.
就好像他们和这个孩子到处都是一样。
So she sent me like a huge list.
所以她给我发了一份巨大的清单。
There's all sorts of tricks.
各种伎俩都有。
Like you feed a bottle when they're taking off because it helps with the ear, the counter pressure and all that stuff.
就像你在飞机起飞时喂奶一样，因为它有助于耳朵、反压力和所有这些东西。
A bottle of gin.
一瓶杜松子酒。
So it ended up to be okay.
所以最后就没事了。
And also my sister's kids are like 14 to 19.
我姐姐的孩子也大约 14 岁到 19 岁。
Like they're much older.
好像他们老了很多。
And my sisters are actually great with babies.
我的姐妹们实际上很擅长照顾婴儿。
So the moment I got there, I was like, take this baby, you know, and they just like immediately took, took him off my hands and we're just not enough.
所以当我到达那里的那一刻，我就想，带上这个孩子，你知道，他们就像立即把他从我手中拿走，但我们还不够。
Huge respect for flying by yourself with a five and a half month old baby.
非常尊重自己带着五个半月大的婴儿独自飞行。
Yeah.
是的。
I definitely 100% never did that with either one of my children.
我绝对 100% 从来没有对我的任何一个孩子这样做过。
Yeah.
是的。
So at that young of an age, so.
所以在那么年轻的时候，所以。
Well done.
干得好。
Yeah.
是的。
And a woman doing the exact same thing wouldn't get shit.
一个女人做同样的事情不会有什么问题。
She'd get no one would say anything.
她不会让任何人说什么。
It's so sad, but, but that was a big, I, I felt a lot of like dad's self esteem.
太难过了,但是,但是那是一个很大的,我,我感觉很像爸爸的自尊。
Yeah.
是的。
I felt like I did this.
我感觉我就是这么做的。
I can do this.
我可以做到这一点。
And also I can move through the world with this baby, right?
而且我可以带着这个宝宝走遍世界，对吗？
It's not just a hostage situation in your lovely apartment in Brooklyn.
这不仅仅是你布鲁克林可爱公寓里的人质事件。
It's I get to move through the world sometimes too.
有时我也会在这个世界上走动。
And it's nice, it's nice to remember that.
这很好，很高兴记住这一点。
You can see the family and so that was great.
你可以看到家人，这真是太棒了。
I mean, that was a big notable thing over our little tiny hiatus.
我的意思是，这是我们短暂休息期间的一件值得注意的大事。
What did we have for how many other, we had like four and a half months, like you could really do things.
我们有多少其他的时间，我们有大约四个半月的时间，就像你真的可以做一些事情一样。
The actors had more than the writers.
演员比编剧有更多的东西。
That's true.
这是真的。
He says, come on literally.
他说，字面意义上的来吧。
This is always the thing I forget.
这始终是我忘记的事情。
This is my little extra crack.
这是我的一点额外裂缝。
What did you guys do this summer?
今年夏天你们都做了什么？
Wrote the goddamn show, actors.
写了该死的节目，演员们。
Nice tan.
晒黑的很好。
But you looked as super tan and all races.
但你看起来晒得黝黑，适合所有种族。
You looked super tan.
你看起来晒得很黑。
That happened every time in August when you guys came back.
每次八月份你们回来的时候都会发生这种情况。
So we take like, what, we would take May and June and start up sometime in the writer's room and I don't know, late June or July.
所以我们会在五月和六月开始，在作家的房间里开始，我不知道是六月底还是七月。
I'm probably getting it wrong.
我可能理解错了。
It's something like that.
就是这样的。
So that we had five or six scripts written in some state of being written by one would be shooting mid-August, late August.
因此，我们有五六个剧本以某种状态编写，其中一人将在八月中旬、八月下旬拍摄。
And this was a bit, we were talking about this before we started recording.
这是一点，我们在开始录制之前就在谈论这个。
This was a big, between season two and season three, that was a big hiatus in your life and my life in very different ways.
这是第二季和第三季之间的一个重大事件，以非常不同的方式，对你和我的生活来说是一个很大的中断。
A lot happened in our personal lives and in our psyches and in our souls during that time.
在那段时间里，我们的个人生活、心灵和灵魂发生了很多事情。
So much so that we're gonna talk about it as its own separate, but let's just see it up a little bit.
如此之多以至于我们要把它作为一个单独的部分来讨论，但让我们稍微看看它。
So that was the summer your son was born, Elliot between seasons two and three.
那是你儿子出生的那个夏天，埃利奥特在第二季和第三季之间。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah, my son Elliot was more between seasons two and three and talked about this on the pod before, but it was very unexpectedly challenging and chaotic.
是的，我的儿子埃利奥特更多地在第二季和第三季之间，之前在播客上谈到过这个，但这是非常出乎意料的挑战和混乱。
He had, he was born with a rare genetic syndrome.
他生来就患有一种罕见的遗传综合症。
We had no idea in utero, like he was born and something was wrong and he was lower weight and he wasn't breathing quite right.
我们对他在子宫里的情况一无所知，就像他出生了一样，出了什么问题，他的体重减轻了，呼吸也不太正常。
He turned out he had multiple heart defects it's rare genetic syndrome.
结果他发现自己患有多种心脏缺陷，这是一种罕见的遗传综合症。
He needed open heart surgery at two weeks old in Children's Hospital, Los Angeles saved his life without question.
两周大的他需要在洛杉矶儿童医院接受心脏直视手术，毫无疑问挽救了他的生命。
And this was all happening between we finished season two and season three was the barreling towards me.
这一切都发生在我们完成第二季和第三季之间。
And it was like I was in the neonatal intensive care unit at CHLA where they're for almost six weeks.
这就像我在 CHLA 的新生儿重症监护室待了将近六个星期。
And this is my first kid, this is my introduction to parenthood and being told he's gonna have all these challenges in life.
这是我的第一个孩子，这是我对为人父母的介绍，我被告知他将面临生活中的所有这些挑战。
And it was really, really hard.
这真的非常非常困难。
So coming back to season three was weird and hard and also so healing and great to get to come back and be creative with these people I love, yourself very much included.
所以回到第三季是很奇怪和困难的，但也很治愈，很高兴能回来和这些我爱的人一起发挥创造力，包括你自己。
And so I have a lab to say about that journey at some point.
因此，我有一个实验室可以在某个时候讲述这段旅程。
What was the name of the podcast you wanted to do?
您想做的播客的名称是什么？
Yeah, well, maybe we'll still do this one day.
是的，好吧，也许有一天我们仍然会这样做。
We wanted to do a pod game.
我们想做一款 Pod 游戏。
So when I would come to the writer's room at the very start of season three, I'd first go to Carter's office or my office and sit just with Carter and me alone in a room, knowing that we had to launch season three, day one of season three and day two and day three.
因此，当我在第三季开始时来到编剧房间时，我会首先去卡特的办公室或我的办公室，与卡特和我单独坐在一个房间里，因为我知道我们必须推出第三季、第三季的第一天、第二天和第三天。
And every morning we would sit down on the couch and we'd just look at each other and I looked like a shell of a human being.
每天早上我们都会坐在沙发上，互相看着对方，我看起来就像一个人的躯壳。
I was just gray and I just looked like I was dying.
我的脸色灰白，看起来就像快要死了。
And we'd look at each other and go, now go be funny.
我们互相看着对方，然后走，现在去搞笑吧。
Yeah, now go be funny.
是的，现在去搞笑吧。
I wanted to and maybe still want to do a vodcast or maybe we could just sort of trojan horse it into this podcast and just talk about it here.
我想做，也许仍然想做一个播客，或者也许我们可以将特洛伊木马植入到这个播客中，然后在这里讨论它。
But just that idea of how do you go make comedy when you're going through the darkest thing and that you can almost possibly go through.
但就是当你正在经历最黑暗的事情并且你几乎有可能经历的时候，你如何去制作喜剧的想法。
And that was the now go be funny of it all.
这就是现在让这一切变得有趣的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
Well, I'd have to go do that.
好吧，我必须去做那件事。
It was really looking forward to doing a deeper dive with you just talking about those summers.
我真的很期待与您更深入地谈论那些夏天。
That's that summer in particular.
尤其是那个夏天。
Me too.
我也是。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I mean, I'll just tee up mine.
是的，我的意思是，我会做好我的准备。
I maybe due to some kind of weird combination combination of, you know, being destabilized from losing anonymity and being on this show.
我可能是由于某种奇怪的组合，你知道，因为失去匿名性和参加这个节目而不稳定。
And I don't know.
我不知道。
I just needed something.
我只是需要一些东西。
I needed a spiritual chiropractic adjustment.
我需要精神上的脊椎按摩调整。
So I ended up going to Brazil and then Colombia.
所以我最终去了巴西，然后是哥伦比亚。
I worked with an ancient Amazonian plant medicine called ayahuasca.
我研究了一种古老的亚马逊植物药，叫做死藤水。
This is 2007.
这是2007年。
And it really changed my life and opened me up in all sorts of wonderful, magical ways, and it kind of changed my relationship with the show, it changed my relationship, but interestingly, because this does segue into, I told Jordana when we were watching it, because we have that flashback to the end of season two.
它确实改变了我的生活，以各种奇妙、神奇的方式让我敞开心扉，它在某种程度上改变了我与这部剧的关系，它改变了我的关系，但有趣的是，因为这确实延续到了，我在看它时告诉乔丹娜，因为我们有第二季结尾的闪回。
And I pointed to her, I said, pre-Iowaska, and then it cuts back to me, you know, in season three, I said post-Iowaska.
我指着她，我说，在爱荷华州之前，然后它又回到了我身上，你知道，在第三季，我说在爱荷华州之后。
And I'm telling you, to me, I look like I'm clearer behind the eyes.
我告诉你，对我来说，我的眼睛看起来更加清晰。
I look like there's been some kind of change because I was, I also stopped drinking and I remember I was drinking a lot in season two and I could kind of see it in my face and I just felt so much healthier when I came back for season three.
我看起来好像发生了某种变化，因为我也戒酒了，我记得我在第二季喝了很多酒，我可以从我的脸上看到它，当我回来参加第三季时，我感觉更健康了。
So much felt different and it was strange to be thrown back into this network sitcom after those, you know, yeah, in crazy adventures down there.
感觉很不一样，在经历了那些疯狂的冒险之后，又回到这部网络情景喜剧中，感觉很奇怪。
Yeah.
是的。
But I actually found myself loving these two, these first two episodes that, that last night with Jordana.
但我实际上发现自己很喜欢这两集，前两集，昨晚和乔丹娜在一起的那集。
But let's, we're talking about episode one of season three right now, which is called, which is called wait for it, which because we ended season two in the middle of a, we ended it on a wait for it midward.
但是，我们现在谈论的是第三季的第一集，这就是所谓的等待它，因为我们在中间结束了第二季，所以我们在中间等待它结束了它。
I love that we ended before the final syllable, the final two syllables of the dairy.
我喜欢我们在最后一个音节，乳制品的最后两个音节之前结束。
And then we finish it.
然后我们完成它。
We have to wait all summer to finish a single word.
我们必须等待整个夏天才能完成一个字。
I really, that's one of my favorites.
我真的，这是我的最爱之一。
It's kind of the Marshall making popcorn, but longer.
这有点像马歇尔制作的爆米花，但时间更长。
It's the full summer popcorn.
这是完整的夏季爆米花。
But yeah, I, it's funny just to go off what you just said.
但是，是的，我，放弃你刚才所说的话很有趣。
I did feel like you had a very loose, like, um, in the, in the pocket, in the flow kind of energy right off the bat in, in this episode, like it, it very much begins, it begins with this great TED cold open.
我确实觉得你有一种非常松散的，嗯，在口袋里，在流动的能量中，在这一集里，就像它一样，它非常开始，它从这个伟大的 TED 冷开场开始。
If we're just diving and talking about it where you have this beard.
如果我们只是在你留着胡子的地方谈论它。
Josh Radner has this beard and Ted has this beard.
乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）有这个胡子，泰德（Ted）也有这个胡子。
And it was your pitch, which again, is like, you came in cooking, you were like, I gotta get rid of this beard in real life.
这是你的推销，就像，你进来做饭，你就像，我必须在现实生活中去掉胡子。
Like, and I actually am going to shave this beard.
就像，我实际上要剃掉胡子。
And you said, whenever a guy shaves a beard.
你说，每当一个人剃胡子的时候。
Hold on real quick.
坚持得真快。
No, you helped me tell it.
不，你帮我说的。
No, no, no, but I just want to make sure.
不不不，但我只是想确认一下。
Was the breakup beard, it was in the script before I even said this.
是分手时的胡子，在我说这句话之前剧本里就有了。
And I can't remember chicken or the egg because maybe you told us you were coming home with a big beard.
我不记得先有鸡还是先有蛋，因为也许你告诉我们你会留着大胡子回家。
Oh, maybe.
哦，也许吧。
because it's a break up beer.
因为这是分手啤酒。
I don't remember if he thought of it.
我不记得他是否想到了。
It's also funny, isn't it funny?
这也很有趣，不是很有趣吗？
This is just occurring to me.
这只是发生在我身上。
It's all about Robin had been in South America, but I had actually been in South America.
这都是因为罗宾去过南美，但我实际上也去过南美。
It's so weird.
太奇怪了。
Robin's plot was actually what you did.
罗宾的阴谋实际上就是你所做的。
It's so weird.
太奇怪了。
I had sex with a guy on a wincer thing.
我和一个男人发生了性关系。
That's a really attractive dude.
这真是一个很有魅力的家伙。
Yeah, I had sex on a wincer thing forward.
是的，我在一个畏缩的事情上发生了性关系。
Yeah, no, so here was my memory of it.
是的，不，这是我的记忆。
This is how I remember it.
我是这样记住的。
The breakup beard was written, But the way it was in the Monday draft we read was he goes into the bathroom and he comes out and he's clean shaven.
分手时的胡子是写的，但我们读到的周一草稿是这样的，他走进浴室，出来后，胡子刮得很干净。
And that's when I pulled you in Carter's side and I said, no man in the history of the world with a full beard shaves just completely.
就在那时，我把你拉到卡特身边，我说，世界历史上没有一个留着大胡子的人会完全剃光。
You shave in chops, you shave in a soul patch, you shave in a goat.
你在排骨上刮胡子，你在灵魂补丁上刮胡子，你在山羊身上刮胡子。
You stop and you stop and you see, what would I look like with a mustache?
你停下来，停下来，你看看，我留着小胡子会是什么样子？
What would I look like?
我会是什么样子？
Here's me as Hitler.
这是我扮演的希特勒。
We didn't do Hitler, but you know what I mean?
我们没有拍希特勒，但你知道我的意思吗？
Like here's what I would look like.
这就是我的样子。
So I pitched that, and people ask me like, oh, how much did you guys, and there's a couple things that I remember I pitched, and this was one of them.
所以我提出了这个，人们问我，哦，你们花了多少钱，我记得我提出了几件事，这就是其中之一。
I didn't write all the jokes that you guys came up with Chester A.
你们和切斯特·A 一起想出的所有笑话都不是我写的。
Arthur, Persian nightclub owner, like all of those.
亚瑟，波斯夜总会老板，就像所有这些人一样。
But you gave us, you gave us the candy store to go play in.
但你给了我们，你给了我们糖果店去玩。
Yeah, I said he should come out each time with a different variation.
是的，我说过他应该每次都推出不同的版本。
And also one thing I really like about it is he doesn't comment on it, they comment on it.
我真正喜欢的一件事是他不对此发表评论，而是他们发表评论。
Like he just comes out and he's in his own thing.
就像他刚刚出来一样，他在做自己的事情。
He's in his own thing about Robin and about just like, yeah, and coming back.
他对罗宾有自己的看法，就像，是的，还有回来。
Yeah, did you, the literally how that was done, was it like we would shoot those takes, cause I was on to my wife Rebecca and she was like, you must have had to be very confident.
是的，你知道吗，从字面上看，这是如何完成的，就像我们会拍摄这些镜头一样，因为我对着我的妻子丽贝卡，她说，你必须非常自信。
You got those takes right before Josh runs off and like hair and makeup takes more off that beard.
你在乔什逃跑之前就得到了这些镜头，比如头发和化妆让胡子变得更多。
And I was like, yeah, I guess we really had to be sure that we really, the audio was good.
我当时想，是的，我想我们真的必须确保音频真的很好。
I do remember that they wouldn't, they didn't shave me on set.
我记得他们不会，他们没有在片场给我刮胡子。
Like I had to go outside to the hair and makeup trailer each time.
就像我每次都必须到外面去做头发和化妆拖车一样。
I forgot that.
我忘记了。
I was wondering if someone was waiting right off, but I guess not.
我想知道是否有人正在等待，但我想没有。
We had to stop it.
我们必须阻止它。
We had time, we had time.
我们有时间，我们有时间。
So yeah, I do remember that.
是的，我确实记得这一点。
And I think beards are makeup, right?
我认为胡须就是化妆，对吧？
So that was Lona who would have been shaving me.
原来是洛娜给我刮胡子的。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And they all looked great.
他们看起来都很棒。
Or maybe Jen did.
或者也许珍做到了。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
You had a hell of a beard.
你的胡子真厉害。
That was a hell of a beard.
那是一个地狱般的胡子。
That was a good beard.
那是一把好胡子。
That was a big, that was like a full, that was very fun.
那是一个大的，那就像一个完整的，那是非常有趣的。
Those bits were great.
这些都很棒。
And so it just, it's shot out of a cannon right away.
就这样，它立即从大炮中射出。
I love picking up on the dairy.
我喜欢吃奶制品。
I just love, I love the way we ended season two, coming right back on that.
我只是喜欢，我喜欢我们结束第二季的方式，然后就回来了。
And then that way of getting through the summer and jumping all that time, and you have a beard, it feels like a summer past.
然后就这样度过夏天，一直跳跃，留着胡子，感觉就像夏天过去了。
Cause it really did.
因为它确实做到了。
And you really passed.
而你真的通过了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Time has passed.
时间已经过去了。
It was, that was again, like honoring, like we did Halloween when it was Halloween.
这又是一种荣誉，就像我们在万圣节时庆祝万圣节一样。
We did New Year's when it was new.
当它是新的时候我们就过新年了。
You know, we were, which wouldn't happen anymore.
你知道，我们曾经是，但这种情况不会再发生了。
I'm streaming.
我正在直播。
No, it doesn't.
不，事实并非如此。
No one does this anymore, but we really did wet ourselves to the air dates in a way.
没有人再这么做了，但我们确实在某种程度上把自己弄湿了。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了在纽约为你唱歌。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
So for people who haven't seen it or maybe haven't seen it for a while, just remind us what happens in this episode.
所以对于那些还没看过或者可能已经有一段时间没看过的人来说，提醒我们这一集中发生了什么。
Like what's the general shape in this episode?
比如说这一集的总体形状是怎样的？
General shape?
一般形状？
Nice.
好的。
General in many beard shapes.
常见于许多胡须形状。
The big question of this episode is this idea of who's winning the breakup, Ted and Robin broke up at the end of season two.
这一集的最大问题是谁赢得了分手，泰德和罗宾在第二季结束时分手了。
And it's that thing of like, well, we're all still going to be friends, I guess.
就好像，好吧，我想我们仍然会成为朋友。
She was away for a bunch of the summer.
她整个夏天都在外面。
They haven't seen each other.
他们还没有见过对方。
What's it going to be like?
会是什么样子？
She comes back with this really hot dude in Ricky Iglesias and Ted realizes it's on.
她带着瑞奇·伊格莱西亚斯（Ricky Iglesias）这个非常性感的家伙回来了，泰德意识到它已经开始了。
The competition is on.
比赛正在进行中。
I have to prove that I have to win this breakup.
我必须证明我必须赢得这次分手。
She's trying to win it.
她正在努力赢得胜利。
clearly trying to win it, but I have to win it.
显然我想赢得它，但我必须赢得它。
And I think that's a very real thing.
我认为这是非常真实的事情。
And then the sub, the sort of B plot of it is this other interesting philosophical question of, what do you owe to your friend?
然后是另一个有趣的哲学问题：你欠你的朋友什么？
Or what if God forbid two of your friends were in a relationship and they break up?
或者如果上帝禁止你的两个朋友谈恋爱并且他们分手了怎么办？
And of course, Lillian Marshall goes so much farther back with Ted.
当然，莉莲·马歇尔和泰德的关系可以追溯到更早的时候。
But they love Robin and is it their duty to just abjectly hate Robin's new guy and agree with Ted that Robin is trying to win the breakup and being nefarious.
但他们爱罗宾，他们有责任极度讨厌罗宾的新男友，并同意泰德的观点，认为罗宾试图赢得分手，而且是邪恶的。
Or are they allowed to think, well, Robin's happy and you're wrong, Ted.
或者他们是否可以认为，好吧，罗宾很高兴，而你错了，特德。
This is not some conspiracy against you.
这不是针对你的阴谋。
And so I love them being sort of seduced into liking.
所以我喜欢他们被引诱喜欢。
They can't help but sort of fall in love with the big egg laziest, so those are the two threads.
他们情不自禁地爱上了最懒的大蛋，所以这就是两条线索。
The power of it is over, it would overwhelm anyone.
它的力量已经结束，它可以压垮任何人。
Yes, and they get very seduced, Marshall included.
是的，他们很受诱惑，包括马歇尔。
I remember really thinking it was funny when we are all in the booth mispronouncing, like our inability to pronounce his name.
我记得当我们都在展位上发音错误时，我真的觉得这很有趣，就像我们无法发音他的名字一样。
Girl?
女孩？
How'd you guys decide on Argentina?
你们怎么决定选择阿根廷呢？
Like, where did that come from?
就像，那是从哪里来的？
Like, I know it was planted that Robin, like, didn't she say in the break?
就像，我知道罗宾是被人陷害的，她不是在中场休息时说过吗？
Like, I haven't ever been to Argentina.
话说我还没去过阿根廷呢
Like, that was kind of like it.
就像，有点像。
That's why we call this shot.
这就是我们决定这样做的原因。
We said, and the minute she's single again, if she's saying I'm single, I want to be single because I want to go explore the world and be a journalist and go have adventures, we thought that she has to go do that.
我们说，一旦她再次单身，如果她说我单身，我想单身，因为我想去探索世界，成为一名记者，去冒险，我们认为她必须这样做。
She broke up with Ted to go do things like that freely on her own and that's why.
她和特德分手是为了自己自由地做这样的事情，这就是原因。
It's a great, you know, cause you guys are exploring all aspects of being in relationships and of course, ending relationships.
你知道，这很棒，因为你们正在探索恋爱关系的各个方面，当然还有结束恋爱关系。
And then who are you when you're out of a relationship?
那么当你脱离一段关系时你是谁？
I know that for me, I didn't have particularly good boundaries in my 20s, certainly in relationships.
我知道对我来说，20多岁的时候我并没有特别好的界限，尤其是在人际关系方面。
So relationships, especially those early breakups, are so hard because you don't know yourself as well, and you end up kind of wedding yourself, not literally, but like you, there's just more codependency, you just get, and I think that it's a really great thing to explore, like, who are you now that you're no longer relationally kind of tied to this person?
所以，人际关系，尤其是那些早期的分手，是如此困难，因为你也不了解自己，你最终会自己结婚，不是字面上的，而是像你一样，只是有更多的相互依赖，你只是得到，我认为探索是一件非常好的事情，比如，你现在是谁，因为你不再与这个人有关系了？
And what does it do to this group?
它对这个群体有什么作用？
Each season of the show very much mixes up the biological ecosystem of this little world of these people.
该剧的每一季都非常混合了这些人的这个小世界的生物生态系统。
And that was one of the main takeaways of this episode.
这是本集的主要收获之一。
I was like, as proud of us that every season we really shook up the yet just sketch.
我为我们感到自豪，每一季我们都真正改变了最初的草图。
And we said, let's draw a new picture.
我们说，让我们画一幅新图画吧。
Let's see what this is now.
现在让我们看看这是什么。
Cause the dynamic has really changed right, right away.
因为动态确实立即发生了变化。
And it's fraud.
这是欺诈。
It's very fraud.
这是非常欺诈的。
I thought you played it great.
我以为你打得很棒。
Just the, I'm not ready.
只是，我还没准备好。
I'm not ready.
我还没准备好。
The calm guy all walks in.
那个冷静的家伙全都走了进来。
Okay, I'm ready.
好的，我准备好了。
I mean, game on.
我的意思是，比赛开始。
I got to get back out there with Barney.
我必须和巴尼一起回到那里。
I've got to like get, got to hook up with whoever I possibly can.
我必须喜欢得到，必须与任何可能的人交往。
And that's what happens.
这就是发生的事情。
It's such a human thing to, you know, to wanna win the breakup to be the more okay person.
你知道，想要赢得分手，成为一个更好的人，这是人之常情。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, to have landed on your feet the best.
你知道，双脚落地是最好的。
And the second you wanna prove that it's ruined.
当你想证明它已经毁了的那一刻。
You're not achieving it, the second you're trying to prove it.
当你试图证明它时，你还没有实现它。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Rebecca, we were watching, one of our hardest laps of the episode was the, okay, I'm ready.
丽贝卡，我们正在观看，这一集最艰难的一圈是，好吧，我准备好了。
And I think it was because it's so, just so human.
我认为这是因为它是如此、如此人性化。
It's like, you played that so great, We're watching a whole summer go by.
就像，你打得太棒了，我们看着整个夏天过去。
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm ready.
我没事，我没事，我没事，我准备好了。
And it felt like the starting gun is fired of this race we're gonna see.
感觉就像我们即将看到的这场比赛的发令枪已经打响。
Who's gonna win the breakup?
分手谁会赢？
And of course, in the end, it's nobody, and Robin's not even trying to win the breakup.
当然，最终，没有人，罗宾甚至没有试图赢得分手。
And she was much more hurt and had a much harder time than Ted knew, and thank God she admitted that to Ted in the end, and that's what keeps them friends.
她受到的伤害比泰德想象的要严重得多，经历的困难要多得多，感谢上帝，她最终向泰德承认了这一点，这就是他们保持朋友关系的原因。
We'll get there, but the scene with Ted and Robin at her apartment door is actually weirdly one of my favorite Ted and Robin scenes.
我们会到达那里，但奇怪的是，泰德和罗宾在她公寓门口的场景实际上是我最喜欢的泰德和罗宾场景之一。
Like I think it's so like spunky and funny and like it feels like they know each other really well by that point It's you know what I mean?
我觉得这感觉就像是充满活力和有趣，感觉他们彼此已经非常了解了，你知道我的意思吗？
There's there's there's no bullshit.
那里有，没有废话。
I love that scene too I want to hear what that felt like although I keep thinking about New York actual Mapping and I'm like who just darts down the Brooklyn from the Upper West you can't get over that one You can't get over that one.
我也喜欢那个场景，我想听听那是什么感觉，尽管我一直在思考纽约的实际地图，我就像谁只是从上西区飞奔到布鲁克林，你无法克服那个，你无法克服那个。
You're like it's too fucking far.
你觉得这太他妈遥远了。
You're in 10 really bothers you because you live in Brooklyn now.
你十岁了真的很困扰你，因为你现在住在布鲁克林。
So you're really you're in Team Brooklyn.
所以你确实是布鲁克林队的一员。
When you live in Brooklyn, a trip to Manhattan is like, okay, get the covered wagon.
当你住在布鲁克林时，去曼哈顿旅行就像，好吧，乘坐有篷马车。
The covered wagon, we're making a trip to Manhattan.
敞篷马车，我们要去曼哈顿旅行。
We'll have to stop and make baked beans overnight.
我们得停下来烤豆子过夜。
Yeah, it's impossible to get to Manhattan.
是的，去曼哈顿是不可能的。
The cow will go to the bathroom.
牛会去洗手间。
Yeah, it is.
是的，确实如此。
It's a frickin' hike.
这是一次该死的徒步旅行。
But yes, let's get to that scene.
但是，是的，让我们来看看那个场景。
The other thing that I wanted to point out, the butterfly tattoo, you had a lot of beard stunts and then you had like a tattoo stuff.
我想指出的另一件事是蝴蝶纹身，你有很多胡子特技，然后你有纹身的东西。
Like this is a very, your body went through a lot in this episode, that's S.
就像这是一个非常，你的身体在这一集中经历了很多，那就是S。
B is yet again, the thing you think would just be completely made up, isn't entirely made up.
B又是，你认为完全是编出来的东西，其实并不是完全编出来的。
Dave Hemmingsen, who became a writer on Hemmium season three, who's a great writer, he went on many years later to write the movie, The Holdovers, by a great movie.
戴夫·海明森（Dave Hemmingsen）成为《Hemmium》第三季的编剧，他是一位伟大的作家，多年后他继续写了一部伟大的电影《The Holdovers》。
Great movie.
很棒的电影。
It's a great movie.
这是一部很棒的电影。
Dave Hemingson, Hemi, very funny.
戴夫·海明森，海米，非常有趣。
He was a little...
他当时有点...
I remember law school grad, wasn't he?
我记得他是法学院毕业生，不是吗？
But he's a lawyer.
但他是一名律师。
He had been a lawyer.
他曾是一名律师。
Yeah, he's a really smart dude.
是的，他是一个非常聪明的家伙。
And he wrote for Hemiim for season three.
他还为 Hemiim 撰写了第三季的剧本。
And he, we were trying to think of like, what can Ted do, you know, to...
而他，我们试图思考，特德可以做什么，你知道，......
What insane night does Ted have and what does he wake up with the next morning?
特德度过了一个怎样疯狂的夜晚？第二天早上他醒来时又看到了什么？
I guess it's a little pineapple incident.
我猜这是一个小菠萝事件。
But Hemingson said, okay, not long ago, I was on the beach in Venice.
但海明森说，好吧，不久前，我在威尼斯的海滩上。
I think maybe he lived in Venice Beach.
我想也许他住在威尼斯海滩。
and like a bare-chested muscular, like macho-looking guy, ran by me, says Hemi.
赫米说，就像一个赤裸上身的肌肉男，看起来很有男子气概的男人，从我身边跑过。
And we sort of watched him go, my wife and I, my wife is probably looking at him, I got guys pretty hot.
我们看着他离开，我和我的妻子，我的妻子可能正在看着他，我的男人们都很性感。
And as he ran past us, and we saw the back of him, there was a butterfly tattoo, right, where Ted winds up getting a butterfly tattoo.
当他跑过我们身边时，我们看到他的背影，右边有一个蝴蝶纹身，特德最后也纹了一个蝴蝶纹身。
And it just stuck in Heming since he had knew that, he was like, Ted should get a butterfly tattooed in the tramp stamp positioning, and we did it.
海明心里一直有这样的想法，因为他知道，特德应该在流浪汉邮票的位置纹上一只蝴蝶，我们就这么做了。
I remember being like, we can't do that, but then we did it.
我记得我当时想，我们做不到，但后来我们做到了。
It's funny to consider like, you never know when you're being observed by a comedy writer.
想想就很有趣，你永远不知道什么时候你会被喜剧作家观察。
Like, does that guy know?
比如说，那个家伙知道吗？
Did that guy see it ever on TV and go?
那家伙在电视上看到过然后就走了吗？
That's, could that, could I have inspired that?
那就是，我能启发它吗？
Also, I, it was the first time, and maybe I just was not, I don't know, maybe I don't know things, but I think that was the first time I heard the term tramp.
还有，我，这是第一次，也许我只是不是，我不知道，也许我不知道事情，但我想那是我第一次听到流浪汉这个词。
It was, it was for me.
是的，是为了我。
And maybe it was Hemmingson who said that when he was telling that story.
也许是海明森在讲这个故事时说的。
And where I feel like multiple people in the room were like, what now?
我感觉房间里很多人都在想，现在怎么办？
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
I had not entered the cultural lexicon.
我还没有进入文化词典。
Like it's pretty universally accepted.
就像它被普遍接受一样。
That's what we definitely do.
这就是我们绝对要做的。
We didn't invent it, but we definitely boosted that.
我们没有发明它，但我们确实推动了它。
We amplified it.
我们放大了它。
We amplified that.
我们放大了这一点。
And cougar too, I think.
我想还有美洲狮。
Cougar, yeah.
美洲狮，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
It's funny how terms that get so, that permeate, when you introduce them, it's like, It's a big drum roll and it actually looks weird when you look back.
有趣的是，当你介绍这些术语时，它们是如何渗透进来的，就像是，这是一个大鼓声，当你回头看时，它实际上看起来很奇怪。
You're like, wait, that was actually the introduction or I thought it was.
你会说，等等，这实际上是介绍，或者我认为是。
I thought the same thing watching this last night.
昨晚看这个我也有同样的想法。
I was like, I definitely had not heard that for any of the other euphemisms for it.
我当时想，我绝对没有听说过任何其他委婉说法。
That like, I think we were like just using the internet to look them up.
就像，我想我们就像只是使用互联网来查找它们一样。
I think a couple of people in the room were like, what are you talking about?
我想房间里有几个人会问，你在说什么？
You know, Panama City license plate.
你知道，巴拿马城车牌。
We're like, what the fuck are you talking about?
我们就像，你他妈的在说什么？
Like, a couple of people knew these.
就像，有几个人知道这些。
I'm like, you're actively everyone's supposed to know this.
我想，你很积极，每个人都应该知道这一点。
I've never heard of this.
我从来没有听说过这个。
but it was great.
但这太棒了。
I always think it's funny that like, in just like a couple years, like Ted gets massively blackout drunk and wakes up multiple times of what has gone on and no one pulls him aside and is like, buddy.
我一直觉得很有趣的是，在短短几年内，泰德喝得酩酊大醉，多次从发生的事情中醒来，却没有人把他拉到一边，就像，伙计。
I know.
我知道。
It's because I had stopped drinking that summer, but like, why doesn't someone, like- It's concerning.
这是因为那年夏天我已经戒酒了，但是，为什么没有人，比如——这很令人担忧。
And they have an intervention banner just sitting there.
他们有一个干预横幅就在那里。
They never do an intervention for drinking.
他们从不对饮酒进行干预。
They only do interventions for non-drinking things.
他们只对非饮酒的事情进行干预。
It's just like, stop wearing those crocs.
就像，别再穿那些鳄鱼鞋了。
Let's go get drunk.
我们去喝醉吧。
It's not, yeah, you know, they could have, at least one time, like, that's a lot of blackouts.
是的，你知道，他们至少可以有一次，比如，大量的停电。
That's actually quite, like it's true.
这确实是真的，就像是真的一样。
It's a lot of blackouts with real consequences.
大量停电造成了实际后果。
Like a potentially dead woman in your bed.
就像你床上一个可能死去的女人。
Tattooed.
纹身的。
You know what?
你知道吗？
It was funny how much the tattoo was dropped in the end of the episode, and it does come back.
有趣的是，在这一集的最后，纹身掉了多少，而且它确实又回来了。
It's a whole storyline later.
后面就是整个故事情节了。
Getting rid of this tattoo.
摆脱这个纹身。
But I will say I love the episode, but in the end of the episode, I really wanted us to have written a scene where they're like, what the fuck are we going to do about this tattoo, Ted?
但我会说我喜欢这一集，但在这一集的最后，我真的希望我们写一个场景，他们就像，我们他妈的要对这个纹身做什么，特德？
Like, this has got to come off of you.
就像，这件事必须由你来解决。
Like, the fact that we just dropped it.
就像我们刚刚放弃它的事实一样。
And now it's just like 10, Robin, are working this thing out.
现在罗宾，好像有 10 个人正在解决这个问题。
Ted's got a fucking butterfly above his ass.
特德的屁股上方有一只该死的蝴蝶。
This is a real problem.
这是一个真正的问题。
But I love that line of just hung over Ted's irrationally trying to like use water on it as if that's going to get it out.
但我喜欢泰德不合理地试图用水浇它的那句话，就好像这样就能把它弄出来一样。
and Marshall's like, you might want to try some club soda.
马歇尔说，你可能想尝尝苏打水。
That's not, I really, that line.
我真的不是那条线。
You know what else maybe left though, when you see the like writers trying to do a hard turn into a transition.
当你看到类似的作家试图艰难地转变为过渡时，你知道还剩下什么。
Yes.
是的。
I mean, he says, I need some ointment or something.
我的意思是，他说，我需要一些药膏什么的。
That is a thing with line.
那是有线条的东西。
I do think I sold that as well as you could possibly do it.
我确实认为我卖得和你一样好。
You know what it is, it's all the circuits are jammed.
你知道那是什么，所有的电路都被堵塞了。
It's all the circuits are jammed.
就是所有的电路都卡住了。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
Why did I always get those lines?
为什么我总是收到这些台词？
I don't know, but I'm really sorry because it's a thankless job to have to say all the circuits are jammed or I need some ointment.
我不知道，但我真的很抱歉，因为不得不说所有电路都堵塞了或者我需要一些药膏，这是一件吃力不讨好的工作。
I need some ointment or something.
我需要一些药膏什么的。
And then it's like, wait a minute, Spanish, massage oil or whatever that was.
然后就像，等一下，西班牙，按摩油或其他什么。
That was clunky.
那很笨重。
That was sweaty, as we said.
正如我们所说，那是出汗的。
But I'll tell you, she's up, something so funny.
但我会告诉你，她起来了，这真是太有趣了。
Jordana was laughing so hard at everyone just falling for Gaille.
乔丹娜对每个人都爱上盖尔大笑。
And when you went on seagulls.
当你乘坐海鸥时。
That seagull land.
那个海鸥栖息地。
Is that a meme?
这是一个模因吗？
I feel like that's a meme.
我感觉这就像一个模因。
People mean that all the time, just that shot, and it ends on seagull, and people, yeah, it is so fucking funny.
人们一直在说，就那个镜头，最后以海鸥结束，人们，是的，这太他妈有趣了。
Pam Fryman, perfect, perfectly timed, perfectly directed.
帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman），完美，时机完美，导演完美。
A great pan, yeah, a pan-fryman.
一个很棒的平底锅，是的，一个煎锅。
A pan-fryman, it was a pan-fryman.
一个煎锅，这是一个煎锅。
Why did you say that?
你为什么这么说？
We really shouldn't.
我们真的不应该。
We should've.
我们应该的。
Jason had such an ability to commit to ridiculousness.
杰森有一种做出荒唐事的能力。
I was thinking the same thing, he's just God bless him.
我也这么想，上帝保佑他。
He just looked like he never was trying to preserve his, like, I'm, like, he just, he had no pride about it.
他看起来就像从来没有试图保护他的，就像，我，就像，他只是，他对此没有自豪感。
I really find it impressive.
我真的觉得它令人印象深刻。
Like he, he, he did the most ridiculous things with the most gusto.
像他他他，他以最有兴致的样子，做了最荒唐的事情。
A hundred million percent all the time.
一直都是一亿%。
Like he just, he knew, he just, he is the epitome of he knew the assignment.
就像他一样，他知道，他只是，他是他知道这项任务的缩影。
You know, he is a walking, he knew the assignment.
你知道，他是一个行走的人，他知道任务。
He's just like, this is the bit, I know what the bit is.
他就像，这就是重点，我知道那是什么。
I'm doing it.
我正在做。
And he, when he tucks down below that pillow where the pillow is covering his mouth and just his little eyes are looking up, it's just so fucking funny.
而他，当他躺在枕头下面，枕头盖住他的嘴，只有他的小眼睛向上看时，这真是太他妈有趣了。
And that's all like him.
这就是他的一切。
I don't remember in the script it said he's hugging a pillow.
我不记得剧本里说他抱着枕头。
Like I think that's what Jason found.
我想这就是杰森发现的。
And he found it.
他找到了。
And also like, he turns away from the camera like he can't believe how much feeling he's feeling.
而且，他转身离开镜头，就像他不敢相信自己有如此强烈的感觉。
He's got like a little like, it's so funny.
他有点像，这太有趣了。
It was really funny.
真的很有趣。
And we had two pop, two big pop stars in one episode which was not really the planet just sort of happened And Ricky Iglesias had been pitched to us, I think.
我们有一集有两位流行音乐巨星，这并不是真正的地球只是发生的事情，我认为瑞奇·伊格莱西亚斯已经被推荐给我们了。
CBS liked him, let's get him on.
哥伦比亚广播公司喜欢他，让我们继续吧。
And I think Manny Moore happened after that.
我认为曼尼摩尔在那之后发生了。
It was kind of like, oh, wait, we just, we just stumbled into two pretty significant pop stars.
有点像，哦，等等，我们只是，我们只是偶然遇到了两位非常重要的流行歌星。
An incredible run of pop stars on how we met with other, like, right?
一系列令人难以置信的流行歌星讲述了我们如何与其他人见面，比如，对吧？
Well, George Clinton.
嗯，乔治·克林顿。
Well, George Clinton began.
好吧，乔治·克林顿开始了。
But yeah, I was thinking the same thing.
但是，是的，我也在想同样的事情。
We're not, you know, we're only a few weeks, few short weeks away from Britney Spears at this point, too.
你知道，我们距离布兰妮·斯皮尔斯只有几周、短短几周的时间了。
Oh, one other thing I wanted to say about Gail, that I thought was really funny, is the characters on the show are, they're all like pretty heady people, right?
哦，关于盖尔，我想说的另一件事是，我认为这真的很有趣，剧中的角色是，他们都像非常令人兴奋的人，对吧？
Like they're brainiacs, they went to college, they're, they sit around a booth drinking and making each other laugh with words, right?
就像他们是天才一样，他们上过大学，他们坐在摊位周围喝酒，用言语逗笑对方，对吗？
They're, there's a cerebral quality to their reparté.
他们的回答很有理智。
Yeah.
是的。
And then this guy from Argentina comes in and he like puts them in their bodies.
然后这个来自阿根廷的家伙进来了，他喜欢把它们放进他们的身体里。
like puts them in their senses, right?
就像让他们恢复理智一样，对吧？
And Marshall, Lily, and Robin are all like, absolutely like, when, you know, when you're led out of your body, like out of your mind and into your body, it's quite pleasurable because you forget you have one.
马歇尔、莉莉和罗宾都像，绝对像，当你被带出你的身体，就像离开你的思想进入你的身体时，这是相当令人愉快的，因为你忘记了你有一个。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, you're like, oh my God, like.
你知道，你就像，天哪，就像。
He unlocked something for them.
他为他们解锁了一些东西。
Yeah, he unlocked something like, they're tasting food and they're actually tasting it.
是的，他解锁了类似的东西，他们正在品尝食物，而且他们实际上正在品尝它。
He takes them out of their autopilot.
他让他们脱离了自动驾驶状态。
So I don't want to shit totally on Guy L.
所以我不想完全责备Guy L。
Like, Guy L.
比如，盖伊·L.
There's something to him.
他有事。
He has something to him.
他有东西给他。
He's in the moment.
他就在当下。
And on vacation, it must have been absolutely magical.
在度假时，这一定是绝对神奇的。
Yes.
是的。
Well, that's, and then that's what episode two is about.
嗯，那就是，然后这就是第二集的内容。
That's what our next episode of season three is about.
这就是我们第三季下一集的内容。
But can you transport that back?
但你能把它运回来吗？
Yeah, Ali really made me laugh when she gets embarrassed and she says, I do not shut up.
是的，当阿里感到尴尬时，她真的让我笑了，她说，我不会闭嘴。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah.
是的。
That was, that was, that was about guy.
那是，那是，那是关于家伙的。
It was about you laugh at everything he says or whatever.
这是关于你嘲笑他所说的一切或其他什么。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know what else is really funny is is Marshall, like the guy's accredited, but he has a laminated he checks out.
你知道吗，真正有趣的是马歇尔，就像那个经过认证的人一样，但他检查了层压板。
He's in his cart, I think, damn it, he checks out.
他在他的购物车里，我想，该死，他结账了。
It's laminated, only a professional can have, the like an achievable emanation.
它是层压的，只有专业人士才能拥有，就像可实现的散发一样。
Yeah, yeah, that was really funny.
是啊，是啊，那真的很有趣。
It's like the thing about, I think we talked about this, but like you can go in, anyone will let you into any building if you're carrying a clipboard.
就像这样的事情，我想我们讨论过这个，但是就像你可以进去一样，如果你携带剪贴板，任何人都会让你进入任何建筑物。
Like there are certain like signifiers of like, I'm official.
就像有某些类似的标志一样，我是官方的。
Yeah, or wearing the lanyard.
是的，或者戴上挂绳。
I think wearing a lanyard will really get you anywhere, but that's kind of a lamin, that's a lamination, like the necklace thing with the laminated, like it doesn't even matter what's in the laminated thing, but I guess that's a lamination, you gotta get a lamination will get you in anywhere.
我认为戴挂绳真的可以让你去任何地方，但那是一种层压材料，这是一种层压材料，就像层压材料的项链一样，就像层压材料里有什么并不重要，但我想那是层压材料，你必须得到层压材料才能让你去任何地方。
What's the, I don't we have the old ref, old tech, we have all those terms?
这是怎么回事，我们没有旧的参考文献、旧的技术，我们有所有这些术语吗？
Yeah.
是的。
There's certain, just wardrobe choices, when Ted walks in in that Western shirt for his big doubt.
当特德穿着那件西式衬衫带着他的重大疑问走进来时，确实有一些衣柜选择。
That bothered me a lot.
这让我很困扰。
I said that, I said that out loud.
我说过，我大声说过。
I was like, what is happening with that shirt?
我当时想，那件衬衫怎么了？
There was a weird quasi-western moment in where Joe pretended.
乔假装出现了一个奇怪的准西部片刻。
That would be Old West, like that.
那就是老西部，就像那样。
The Old West, yes, it was the Old West.
老西部，是的，那是老西部。
And what, I guess it was mirroring that that was kind of happening, but it really stood out to me.
我想这反映了正在发生的事情，但它对我来说确实很突出。
And I even found myself thinking like, was that really happening that much in real life?
我什至发现自己在想，现实生活中真的有那么多事情发生吗？
It was also like, I tried to pass off as like, yeah, I just threw this on.
这也就像，我试图假装，是的，我只是把它穿上了。
Yeah, oh my God, that was a rough one.
是的，天哪，那真是太艰难了。
I mean, you're supposed to go by and have like a bad decision.
我的意思是，你应该经过并做出一个错误的决定。
Would he truly have ended up kissing Mandy Moore in that shirt?
他真的会穿着那件衬衫亲吻曼迪摩尔吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
After three seconds, he meets her and three seconds later, he's like, yeah, she's like, I love that cowboy shirt.
三秒钟后，他遇到了她，三秒钟后，他说，是的，她说，我喜欢那件牛仔衬衫。
I really liked her Amy's Burns to Barney.
我真的很喜欢她的《艾米的伯恩斯对巴尼》。
Yeah.
是的。
Although it's great when he calls her Tommy Lee, which I thought was funny.
不过，当他叫她汤米·李时，我觉得这很有趣。
But yeah, her burns to him are, again, like we've kind of been tracking this, like Barney needs the piss taken out of him with some regularity in the show.
但是，是的，她对他的伤害再次，就像我们一直在追踪这件事一样，就像巴尼需要在节目中有规律地从他身上撒尿一样。
Yes, with frequency, great frequency.
是的，有频率，频率很高。
And also that thing of Barney, as much as he talks about wanting to get laid all the time, his tribe is often just wanting Ted's attention.
还有巴尼的事情，尽管他一直在谈论想要上床，但他的部落通常只是想要泰德的关注。
And this is the end of the time he hates the Ted's attention.
他讨厌特德的关注的日子到此为止了。
Cause he's like, we were gonna go, this was wingman reborn.
因为他说，我们要走了，这是僚机重生。
But this is us back out of the town.
但这是我们从城里回来的。
You're already, what's somebody now?
你已经是了，现在什么人了？
Are you supposed to blow up?
你是不是该炸了？
It's like the pursuit of women and sex is almost like, it could be anything.
这就像女性和性的追求几乎一样，它可以是任何东西。
Like if Ted said, let's play laser tag, He'd be like, great.
就像如果特德说，让我们玩激光枪战，他会说，太棒了。
It's just a way for them to spotlight their focus on something that they can do together.
这只是他们将注意力集中在可以一起做的事情上的一种方式。
Yes.
是的。
Well, it's like, this is not my observation, but male friendships are often based on doing something.
嗯，这不是我的观察，但男性友谊往往是建立在做某事的基础上的。
We've got to do something.
我们必须做点什么。
We've got to make something together.
我们必须一起做点什么。
Here we are.
我们到了。
We're all friends, Alex, Josh, and Craig.
我们都是朋友，亚历克斯、乔什和克雷格。
We're making this podcast.
我们正在制作这个播客。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It makes you hang out and bond to make a thing.
它让你们一起出去玩，并建立联系来创造一件事情。
As a guy.
作为一个男人。
Did you ever hear that thing?
你听过那件事吗？
I can never remember what I've said in the previous episodes, But there's that thing that women have like chest to chest friendships and that they face each other and say things to each other.
我永远记不起我在前几集里说过的话，但有一点是，女人之间有一种胸对胸的友谊，她们面对面，互相说话。
And men have shoulder to shoulder friendships where they like sit in a bar and watch, or watch books together, or, you know.
男人们有肩并肩的友谊，他们喜欢坐在酒吧里看，或者一起看书，或者，你知道。
You have to be doing a thing.
你必须做一件事。
And for Tenemore, Barney wants to be out on the hunt.
对于泰尼莫尔，巴尼想要出去狩猎。
He doesn't want them either of them to succeed necessarily because then they won't be hanging out anymore.
他并不希望他们中的任何一个人都成功，因为那样他们就不会再在一起了。
He just wants to be together for a while before success.
他只是想在成功之前先在一起一段时间。
It doesn't matter if success happens.
是否成功并不重要。
And then at the end, when the offer of sax, he's kind of like, yeah, okay.
最后，当萨克斯演奏时，他有点像，是的，好吧。
Yeah, right.
是的，对。
I guess it's good.
我想这很好。
Okay, fine.
好吧，好吧。
Now the Ted's gone.
现在特德不见了。
What's that as well?
那又是什么？
There was.
有。
I remember that hot tub thing was so funny, though.
不过，我记得热水浴缸的事情很有趣。
What's Barney's line like, Ted has a classic, you know, style, never goes out of style.
巴尼的台词是什么样的，泰德有一种经典的风格，你知道，风格永远不会过时。
And ever green cuts, never goes out of style season to season burn.
永远的绿色剪裁，永不过时的时尚燃烧。
It's just like this lovely compliment of Ted's look, but it's as a burr.
这就像对特德外表的可爱赞美，但它是一个毛刺。
Yeah, it's that was really funny That's a really weird for someone who had spent, you know 44 episodes criticizing his sartorial choices.
是的，这真的很有趣，对于一个花了 44 集批评他的着装选择的人来说，这真的很奇怪。
He really actually respects them and on an evening where he's wearing a stupid fucking cow By sure to know this.
他真的很尊重他们，而且在一个晚上他穿着一头愚蠢的他妈的牛，他肯定知道这一点。
This is the one evening Ted didn't have the evergreen classic Loki's And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
这是泰德没有播放常青经典《洛基》的一个晚上，现在是广告，广告结束，回到演出。
I did love getting drunker and drunker is always fun.
我确实喜欢喝醉，喝醉总是很有趣。
And dark, dark, Ted, it was fun to see you go a little dark.
黑暗，黑暗，特德，看到你变得有点黑暗很有趣。
This was not Ted trying to have a magical night where he's going to meet the mother.
特德并不是想度过一个神奇的夜晚，在那里他会见到母亲。
This was Ted wanting to have meaning of sex, to win a breakup with Robin who had a really hot boyfriend.
这是泰德想要拥有性的意义，想要赢得与罗宾的分手，罗宾有一个非常性感的男朋友。
Well, this leads to a larger question that I have for you.
好吧，这引出了我要问你的一个更大的问题。
So I remember at the end of season two, you and Carter came to me and said, you know, we've had Ted be like hunting, you know, pining for Rob and wanting to be in a relationship, always thinking about relationships.
所以我记得在第二季结束时，你和卡特来找我说，你知道，我们让泰德像狩猎一样，你知道，渴望罗伯并想要建立一段关系，总是想着人际关系。
We want to take a little time with Ted where he's just out with Barney on the prowl.
我们想花点时间和特德在一起，他刚刚和巴尼在外面徘徊。
Yes.
是的。
Remember that?
还记得吗？
Yes.
是的。
And I remember you guys were flexing these new kind of muscles with Ted.
我记得你们正在和泰德一起展示这些新的肌肉。
I loved this.
我喜欢这个。
Like I thought it was really fun not to be like the moony eyed relationship guy.
就像我觉得不像那个满眼恋爱的人一样真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Remember, Pam told me, maybe, maybe you guys told me, that the network was like, hold up.
记住，帕姆告诉我，也许，也许你们告诉我，网络就像，等一下。
Right.
正确的。
Hold up.
耽误。
Maybe a little.
也许有一点。
And I remember what Pam said to me was the network said, there's a lot of Barney's on TV.
我记得帕姆对我说的是电视网说的，电视上有很多巴尼的节目。
And I don't mean to flatten out what Neil was doing, which was a very special meaning.
我并不是想平淡尼尔所做的事情，这是一个非常特殊的意义。
There were a lot of cads on TV.
电视上有很多流氓。
There were a lot of guys who were like, just wanted to get laid.
有很多人只是想上床。
Yeah.
是的。
There's only one Ted.
那里只有一个特德。
Right.
正确的。
Like they knew that he was like a special kind of creature.
就像他们知道他是一种特殊的生物一样。
Yes.
是的。
Like in his DNA.
就像他的 DNA 中一样。
And they, I think, went to you and said, can you please bring him back to his kind of original five or sevens.
我想，他们去找你说，你能把他带回到原来的五人制或七人制吗？
Yeah, that may have been a little later in his, cause there's a few moments in season three where Ted is dark.
是的，这可能是他的故事发生得稍晚一些，因为在第三季中，有一些时刻泰德是黑暗的。
Ted's on a bit of a dark spiral.
特德正处于一个黑暗的螺旋之中。
There's this episode, no tomorrow.
有这一集，没有明天。
There's, there's some episodes where he is not his best Ted.
在某些情节中，他并不是最好的特德。
And I think that's what's interesting.
我认为这就是有趣的地方。
I think it's interesting to show that.
我认为展示这一点很有趣。
But it's the same tug of war about the network wanting, you know, CBS didn't always get how much we wanted to shake up the show.
但这也是一场关于电视网想要改变节目的拉锯战，你知道，哥伦比亚广播公司并不总是明白我们有多想改变这个节目。
along the way and the serialized way and show that we're going to do a whole arc where Ted is not the moony-eyed rom-com guy and that rattled them a little bit, I think as I recall.
一路走来，以连载的方式，表明我们将完成一个完整的弧线，其中泰德不是那个满眼浪漫的浪漫喜剧人，我想这让他们有点不安，我想我记得。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I think it's in some ways it's like, that's not the show we bought.
嗯，我认为从某些方面来说，这不是我们买的节目。
We bought the show about this guy.
我们买了关于这个人的节目。
But we said it's a show about growing up and evolution and the chapters you go through and you're not always the same guy and you're not always the best guy, none of us are.
但我们说这是一部关于成长和进化的节目，以及你经历的章节，你并不总是同一个人，你也不总是最好的人，我们都不是。
Did we talk?
我们说话了吗？
No, remind me.
不，提醒我一下。
because I have a small child at home, my brain.
因为我家里有一个小孩子，我的大脑。
It's a little fried.
有点炸了。
But did you, did we talk about that thing about how choices are either hats, haircuts, or tattoos?
但是我们有没有讨论过帽子、发型或纹身的选择？
I can't remember either, so say it again, because it's good.
我也不记得了，所以再说一遍，因为很好。
Okay.
好的。
So this is hilarious because this episode involves a tattoo.
所以这很搞笑，因为这一集涉及纹身。
Yeah.
是的。
But I think James Clear might have said something like this who wrote atomic habits, but the idea is all decisions are either hats, haircuts, or tattoos.
但我认为詹姆斯·克利尔（James Clear）可能会说过这样的话，他写了原子习惯，但他的想法是所有决定要么是帽子，要么是发型，要么是纹身。
Hats are, you try it on, eh, I don't like this, you take it off, very little consequence to that decision.
帽子是，你试戴一下，呃，我不喜欢这个，你把它脱下来，这个决定几乎没有什么后果。
A haircut decision is, okay, longer tail of consequence, but it'll grow back, right?
好吧，剪头发的决定会导致尾巴变长，但它会重新长出来，对吗？
Like eventually it'll grow back.
就像最终它会长回来一样。
A tattoo is a tattoo, you know?
纹身就是纹身，你知道吗？
A tattoo is like, it's there, like you're inked, you know?
纹身就像是，它就在那里，就像你被纹身了一样，你知道吗？
It's like, and it feels like, how are my mother, especially in the 20s era, we're still in, you know, they're now 29, right?
就像，感觉就像，我的母亲怎么样，尤其是在 20 多岁的时代，我们仍然处于，你知道，他们现在 29 岁，对吧？
Something like that.
类似的事情。
Yeah, like, you're still trying on hats, right?
是的，你还在试戴帽子，对吧？
Like you're still, oh, this is just one night, this is just like whatever, but it's funny because Ted gets a tattoo, Marshall gets a terrible haircut, and covers it up with a hat.
就像你仍然，哦，这只是一个晚上，这就像其他什么一样，但这很有趣，因为泰德纹身了，马歇尔剪了一个糟糕的发型，并用帽子遮住了它。
All of these happen, it's true, yeah, yeah.
所有这些都发生了，这是真的，是的，是的。
But I think it's an interesting framework to look at decisions, basically, like, when people in their 20s ask me, you know, for advice or whatever, and I'm like, just, you know, it's like, try on some hats, like try on some different, see what feels good to you because if you're careful and not reckless, like your decisions are like, you can just try on another hat, you know?
但我认为这是一个看待决策的有趣框架，基本上，就像，当 20 多岁的人向我寻求建议或其他什么时，我就像，只是，你知道，就像尝试戴一些帽子，比如尝试不同的帽子，看看什么对你来说感觉很好，因为如果你小心而不鲁莽，就像你的决定一样，你可以尝试戴另一顶帽子，你知道吗？
But then you get older and I think going from hat to hat, like living a hat to hat lifestyle like in your 40s and 50s gets really, like if you haven't made some real decisions and put down some roots and made some real, you know, depth-centered decisions and forge relationships that can get a little sadder.
但随着年龄的增长，我认为从一个帽子换到另一个帽子，就像在 40 多岁和 50 多岁那样过着各种各样的生活方式，就像你没有做出一些真正的决定，扎根，做出一些真正的，你知道的，以深度为中心的决定并建立关系，这可能会变得更加悲伤。
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
是的，是的，我同意。
And it's interesting that Ted literally gets a tattoo.
有趣的是，泰德确实有纹身。
This is the perfect metaphor.
这是一个完美的比喻。
Even if we've said this before, this is the perfect.
即使我们之前已经说过，这也是完美的。
And he has this knight where he's not himself.
他有一个不是他自己的骑士。
He's not his best self.
他还不是最好的自己。
His motivations are very impure.
他的动机非常不纯粹。
Not just trying to have a meaningless hookup, but like defying, winning the breakup, you know?
不仅仅是试图进行毫无意义的勾搭，而是喜欢反抗，赢得分手，你知道吗？
Like that's not a pure motivation.
就像这不是纯粹的动机。
He wants to hurt Robin's feelings the way that his feelings have been hurt.
他想像伤害罗宾一样伤害他的感情。
and he does have a consequence.
他确实有一个后果。
He gets a tattoo, he's not a hat, it's a fucking tattoo.
他有一个纹身，他不是帽子，这是一个该死的纹身。
Right, right.
对，对。
And it becomes a little mini arc.
然后它就变成了一个小弧线。
I like that about this premiere.
我喜欢这个首映式。
He has, there's a problem that has to be solved with this tattoo.
他有，这个纹身有一个问题必须解决。
It does get us a trap as well.
它也确实给我们带来了陷阱。
We've talked about this before, but like, karma exists quite, it's a quite real force in how I met your mother universe.
我们之前讨论过这个，但是，业力确实存在，它是我如何遇见你的母亲宇宙的一个非常真实的力量。
It is, yeah.
是的，是的。
There are consequences to actions.
行动是有后果的。
I also love how Amy's boyfriend is Steve, the tattoo artist.
我也喜欢艾米的男朋友是纹身艺术家史蒂夫。
And that guy, man.
还有那个家伙，伙计。
There are names also, Steve.
还有名字，史蒂夫。
Yeah, that guy's fun.
是的，那家伙很有趣。
You're names also, Steve.
你也是名字，史蒂夫。
That guy was really well cast.
那个人演得真好。
But it's really fun to watch Marshall and Lily and Barney just like.
但看马歇尔、莉莉和巴尼的样子真的很有趣。
Trying to get Ted to say the word butterfly is very joy.
试图让特德说出“蝴蝶”这个词是非常令人高兴的。
Trying to get.
试图得到。
Neil did something that was so, when he first notices the tattoo, he did this thing where he kind of puts his whole, and tries to almost put his whole hand in his mouth.
尼尔做了这样的事情，当他第一次注意到纹身时，他做了这样的事情，他把他的整个手放在嘴里，并试图几乎把他的整只手放进嘴里。
And I think, isn't that what Lenny and Squiggy is?
我想，这不就是莱尼和史奎吉吗？
I think that was Lenny and Shirley.
我想那是莱尼和雪莉。
I do, yeah, that's, yeah.
我愿意，是的，就是这样，是的。
Like they would like bite their hands and stuff.
就像他们想咬自己的手之类的东西一样。
And I was like, Neil is doing like a Lenny and Squiggy reference, I think.
我当时想，尼尔的表现就像莱尼和斯奎吉的参考，我想。
I wonder if that was conscious.
我想知道这是否是有意识的。
I know we got to ask him that.
我知道我们必须问他这个问题。
But it's also funny, like, what do you ask him to get on the top shelf, like?
但这也很有趣，比如，你要他把什么放在最上面的架子上，比如？
Oh, yeah, a fun new pot.
哦，是的，一个有趣的新锅。
And then Marshall's just sitting there with a fun new pot, the rest of the scene.
然后马歇尔就拿着一个有趣的新锅坐在那里，剩下的场景。
I didn't notice that.
我没有注意到这一点。
I forgot it, I think.
我想，我忘记了。
Go back and look, he's just sitting there with it as they're trying to get Ted to say, but it's funny, like, like, Ted is just like, okay, I'll grab you the fondue pot.
回去看看，他只是坐在那里，因为他们想让泰德说，但这很有趣，就像，就像，泰德就像，好吧，我会给你拿火锅锅。
Yeah, I was like, what?
是的，我当时想，什么？
I said that to her.
我对她这么说。
That guy was like, why does Ted wouldn't Ted say, but why?
那家伙说，为什么泰德不说，但为什么呢？
It's not in the morning.
现在不是早上。
I also like when Marshall said, J crew catalog, who brings two golden retrievers to a canoe.
我也喜欢马歇尔说的，J 船员目录，他把两只金毛猎犬带到了独木舟上。
Yeah, that was a good little throw.
是的，那是一个很好的小投球。
Ted has a line in that scene with Robin, where he goes Mr. Adore where he says, he's like the Cadillac of rebound guys.
泰德在那个场景中与罗宾有一句台词，他在那里说，他就像篮板球手中的凯迪拉克。
I have a dim memory that we were sponsored by Cadillac in this episode.
我依稀记得这一集我们是由凯迪拉克赞助的。
Is that true?
这是真的吗？
Oh, fuck.
哦，操。
I'm almost sure that's true.
我几乎确信这是真的。
And that it was literally a product placement line that was as good a product placement line as could ever be.
这实际上是一条产品植入线，是一条尽可能好的产品植入线。
Do you know something?
你知道吗？
I think you're right.
我认为你是对的。
And that's an amazing deep cut memory moment, Josh.
那是一个令人惊叹的深刻记忆时刻，乔什。
I forgot.
我忘了。
I think I blocked that.
我想我阻止了这一点。
I blocked things like that.
我阻止了类似的事情。
If you got the original broadcast, you'd see a Cadillac commercial.
如果您观看原始广播，您会看到凯迪拉克广告。
You were a hundred percent right.
你是百分百正确的。
You're blowing my fucking mind right now.
你现在让我大吃一惊。
I completely, I think I like really put, I filed these like soul crushing things back in some very deep file cabinet way in the back of my head.
我完全，我想我真的喜欢把这些像灵魂破碎的东西归档到我脑后某个非常深的文件柜里。
And it was true.
这是真的。
That's not what you want to remember.
那不是你想记住的。
That's not what you want your sharpest memory to be.
这不是你想要的最敏锐的记忆力。
I watched it go by when I watched the episode last night.
昨晚看这集的时候我就看到它过去了。
And I thought, that's not really a joke.
我想，这并不是一个笑话。
It's kind of like a rebound guys.
这有点像篮板球。
Like it's okay.
好像没事一样。
It's something, it's something I guess.
这是某事，我猜是某事。
I feel like the word Cadillac is the best of the best.
我觉得凯迪拉克这个词是最好的。
Yeah.
是的。
Like that's what the, that's what the assumption is.
这就是假设，这就是假设。
Yeah.
是的。
It's not as bad as, can you get me some ointment or whatever, but it's not.
这并不像你能给我一些药膏什么的那么糟糕，但事实并非如此。
I need some ointment or something.
我需要一些药膏什么的。
Oh, I think we're also sponsored by ointment.
哦，我想我们也是有药膏赞助的。
I think that's why we did that one.
我想这就是我们这样做的原因。
We'd know we'd sadly be voluntarily wrote the ointment line.
我们知道我们会遗憾地自愿写下这行药膏。
Cadillac we were coerced into doing.
凯迪拉克是我们被迫做的。
That was it.
就是这样。
We had to say, I love that scene because you're right.
我们不得不说，我喜欢那个场景，因为你是对的。
you can feel the history.
你可以感受到历史。
And the last time we saw them together, it's, I would have stolen you a whole orchestra, they're covered in red sauce from an Italian restaurant.
上次我们看到他们在一起时，我会偷你整个管弦乐队，他们涂满了意大利餐厅的红酱。
They're hugging each other, it's so tragic.
他们互相拥抱，真是太悲惨了。
And then, you know, Kobe's still got her kind of windswept Argentinian hair.
然后，你知道，科比仍然留着她那种被风吹过的阿根廷头发。
And Ted's got his like, I just got tattooed and I'm probably still shaking off a hangover, but I'm filled with energy and I'm filled with passion.
特德也有他的想法，我刚刚纹身，可能还在摆脱宿醉，但我充满了能量，充满了激情。
And it's like, he doesn't go there to win her back.
就像，他去那里并不是为了赢回她。
He goes there to say, I think this is like crappy of you to like parade this guy in front of my face, which then she says, that's not what I was doing.
他去那里说，我认为你喜欢在我面前炫耀这个家伙，这真是太糟糕了，然后她说，那不是我所做的。
And it's very moving when she says, like, I cried for however long, like I couldn't, you know, I was trying to survive, what did she say I was trying to survive the breakup?
当她说，不管我哭了多久，就像我哭不了一样，你知道，我试图活下去，她说我想在分手后活下去，她说了什么？
I wasn't trying to win it, I was trying to survive it.
我不是想赢得胜利，而是想活下去。
Yes, I was trying to survive it.
是的，我试图活下去。
Yeah, I was trying to survive it, which is actually very sweet.
是的，我试图活下去，这实际上非常甜蜜。
It's very sweet, she was hurt, she was in pain too, and he needed to hear that, you know?
这很甜蜜，她受伤了，她也很痛苦，他需要听到这些，你知道吗？
He, that was a gift she gave him.
他，那是她送给他的礼物。
And also I do think one, I know I say, I never wrote anything, but I remember a tweak that I asked you guys if I could do, or maybe I said it in a run-through and then you guys liked it and actually changed it, where I said, oh, come on, he, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, he massages things, like I said, I'm pretty much talking things was my little tweet.
我也确实认为一个，我知道我说，我从来没有写过任何东西，但我记得我问你们我是否可以做的一个调整，或者也许我在一次演练中说过，然后你们喜欢它并且实际上改变了它，我说，哦，来吧，他，等等，等等，等等，等等，他按摩东西，就像我说的，我几乎在谈论东西是我的小推文。
I think that's true.
我认为这是真的。
And I think you guys liked it and kept it.
我想你们喜欢它并保留它。
But I think it's also really great in that scene, by the way.
但顺便说一句，我认为那个场景也很棒。
You really did that scene great.
你那场戏确实演得很棒。
And your energy of that was really, really interesting.
你的能量真的非常非常有趣。
And it was not something we'd seen Ted do quite.
我们从未见过特德做过这样的事。
It was an interesting ultimatum he was giving.
他发出的最后通牒很有趣。
I think that's what I liked was I got to shift into a different gear.
我想这就是我喜欢的，因为我必须换档。
That wasn't like, love me, love me, be with me, be with me.
那不像，爱我，爱我，和我在一起，和我在一起。
I love you.
我爱你。
Do you love me?
你爱我吗？
Like it was such a different gear, which is like I think you're being unkind yeah, and I don't like it Yeah, you know it there was there was a kind of like Like a propulsive energy to it.
就像这是一个如此不同的装备，就像我认为你不友善是的，我不喜欢它是的，你知道它有一种像推进能量一样。
Yeah, I just need to yell.
是的，我只需要大喊一声。
We never yell That was a I think that was a carter line I think Carter was probably channeling a bunch of his like pre pre marriage breakups in this one Yeah, winning the breakup I feel like Carter was definitely bringing some real wounds into this and I remember loving that we never did this We never yelled.
我们从不大喊那是我认为那是卡特的台词我认为卡特可能在这一场中传达了他的一堆婚前分手是的，赢得了分手我觉得卡特肯定给这件事带来了一些真正的伤害我记得很喜欢我们从来没有这样做过我们从来没有大喊大叫。
So now we have to and I feel like I feel like it was a great Carter observation, but it's such a funny You know, it's such a pedestrian like I like where she said I like the beard.
所以现在我们必须这样做，我觉得这是卡特的一次伟大的观察，但这很有趣，你知道，就像我喜欢她说的我喜欢胡子的地方一样。
I did too And they're going back once it's falling, but yeah, he's just yelling to yell.
我也这么做了，一旦天塌下来，他们就会回去，但是，是的，他只是大喊大叫。
He just has to yell something It's so human Yeah, and they're connecting and she's kind of half smiling at the fact that he's he just has to yell and she lets him And then she says I'm in pain too.
他只需要大喊大叫，这太人性化了是的，他们正在联系，她对他只是大喊大叫的事实感到有点微笑，她让他大喊大叫，然后她说我也很痛苦。
It's actually a lovely scene.
这实际上是一个可爱的场景。
Yeah, I that's cool to hear that you like that scene that much You guys played it really beautiful.
是的，我很高兴听到你这么喜欢那个场景，你们演得非常漂亮。
I really do and I also think The tat I mean the way that they get out of that scene you're bigger is so Funny and also like he's fine.
我真的这么认为，而且我也认为我的意思是，他们从那个场景中摆脱出来的方式让你变大了，这非常有趣，而且他也很好。
It's a very human.
这是一个非常人性化的。
It's very very human.
这是非常非常人性化的。
It's very male Yeah, like and also like a little a little gift I want, does he say I won at the end with the testing?
这是非常男性化的，是的，就像，也像我想要的一点小礼物，他说我最后通过测试赢了吗？
Yeah, I won.
是的，我赢了。
Which is, we're all humans, man, right?
也就是说，我们都是人类，对吧？
We all need, he needed to know, the deeper thing he needed to know was that she was actually hurt and she wasn't just blissfully happy and that she was compensating in some way.
我们都需要，他需要知道，他需要知道的更深层的事情是，她实际上受到了伤害，她不仅仅是幸福快乐，而且她正在以某种方式补偿。
And the cherry on top was Ted's got a bigger dick.
最重要的是特德的鸡巴更大了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, also real quick though, there's a, the, the, the slap that tag is great.
是的，也很快，有一个，这个，这个，标签太棒了。
That, that was, I, I really forgot.
那,那是,我,我真的忘记了。
We did that.
我们做到了。
I totally forgot about that.
我完全忘记了。
I really forgot we did that at the end of that episode.
我真的忘记了我们在那集结尾时这么做了。
And I was like, the fucking balls on us that there's not one mention of the slap that.
我当时就想，我们他妈的蛋蛋上居然没有提到那一巴掌。
No, but that was a reward for people who had been watching.
不，但那是对一直在观看的人的奖励。
That's it.
就是这样。
We're giving, we're really, that is our message and a bottle to the the dedicated viewer were saying, we know you're there.
我们正在给予，我们真的，这就是我们的信息，一瓶酒向热心的观众说，我们知道你在那里。
We know you're watching the show with that level of scrutiny.
我们知道您正在以这种程度的审视观看节目。
And we really love you.
我们真的很爱你。
You have a different level of satisfaction with this show that the drop-in viewer doesn't know.
你对这个节目有不同程度的满意度，这是普通观众所不知道的。
But the drop-in viewer would be like, what in God's name is this?
但路过的观众会想，这到底是什么？
It's not explained.
这没有解释。
It's not enough.
这还不够。
Maybe it was mysterious enough that people would be like, that's intriguing and weird.
也许它足够神秘，人们会觉得，这很有趣，很奇怪。
Yeah.
是的。
This show is maybe weirder than I thought it was.
这个节目可能比我想象的更奇怪。
Well, it was a good one.
嗯，这是一件好事。
I really love this episode.
我真的很喜欢这一集。
I really, again, just to bring it, but we will have a deeper talk about our emotional states headed into this episode at some point.
我真的，再次，只是为了带来它，但我们将在某个时候更深入地讨论我们在这一集的情绪状态。
But this episode meant a lot, it brought me back to life a little bit after I had had, you know, a near death hiatus, certainly an emotional near death and sort of a literal one.
但这一集意义重大，它让我在经历了一次濒临死亡的间歇之后又恢复了一点活力，当然是一种情感上的濒临死亡，而且是一种字面上的濒临死亡。
And coming back and feeling like this show was firing on all its cylinders.
回来后感觉这部剧正在全力以赴。
Oh my God, yeah.
天哪，是的。
Really strong season premiere.
确实很强大的季节首映。
It's hard, season premiere is hard.
这很难，赛季首映很难。
launch a whole new thing, launch a whole new condition, pick up on where you left off, but also spin it into something new, hard stuff to do.
启动一个全新的事物，启动一个全新的条件，从上次停下的地方继续，但也将它变成一些新的、困难的事情。
I actually was really proud of it, watching it.
事实上，我真的很自豪，看着它。
I hadn't watched this one in you.
我没有在你身上看到这一点。
I felt like every character was saying the thing the character would say, if that makes it.
我觉得每个角色都在说这个角色会说的话，如果这样的话。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like Robin was so Robin, and Barney was so Barney, and Ted was so Ted.
就像罗宾就是罗宾，巴尼就是巴尼，泰德就是泰德。
Like everyone was really finally etched in a way that you want it to feel that way.
就像每个人最终都以一种你希望的方式被蚀刻一样。
We were just starting to feel like maybe the show could be a hit, and you're still trying to just prove yourself and prove who these characters are.
我们刚刚开始觉得这部剧可能会大受欢迎，而你仍在努力证明自己并证明这些角色是谁。
And if people are dropping viewers, you're trying to say like, I want this to be crystal clear to you, except the tag, which is gonna confuse the shit out of you.
如果人们正在放弃观看者，你会想说，我希望你能清楚地了解这一点，除了标签，这会让你感到困惑。
But that's also some of the joy.
但这也是一些快乐。
Do you know what Jordana said to me the moment the show, this episode ended?
你知道节目结束时乔丹娜对我说了什么吗？
What?
什么？
She turned her back to me and she said, massage me like Gaiel.
她转过身背对着我，说，像盖尔一样按摩我。
We are now at what we like to call an industry speak, our sea block, Alec, what do you have for us?
我们现在正处于所谓的行业演讲，我们的海域，亚历克，你有什么要告诉我们的吗？
Well, this season, this season, I think if all goes well, and I'm speaking to you all out there, you can hear me, we're going to hear from a bunch of folks who helped make this show kind of behind the scenes as well as in front of the camera, certainly.
好吧，这个赛季，这个赛季，我想如果一切顺利的话，我正在对你们所有人讲话，你们可以听到我的声音，我们肯定会听到一群在幕后和镜头前帮助这部剧的人的声音。
And I do have our first hello for you guys and I'm going to talk about doing more of this Alec.
我确实向你们问好，我将谈论更多关于亚历克的事情。
You shouldn't have.
你不应该这样做。
You will.
你会。
So and so you did it.
你某某做到了。
And this one's going to be from Kelly who started out as a production assistant, but spent most of her time there as the production coordinator.
这个人来自凯莉，她一开始是一名制作助理，但大部分时间都在担任制作协调员。
Hi guys, it's Kelly.
嗨，大家好，我是凯利。
I love that you're doing season three season three holds a very, very special place in my heart because it's the season that I started and it's the season that I met all of you and I just it's basically when I feel like my career I had done a couple of shows before but I feel like it's kind of when my career kind of got its legs I got to spend seven and a half I think glorious seasons with all of you.
我喜欢你正在做的第三季，第三季在我心中占有非常非常特殊的位置，因为这是我开始的赛季，也是我遇见你们所有人的赛季，我只是基本上当我觉得我的职业生涯之前已经做过几场演出，但我觉得当我的职业生涯开始站稳脚跟时，我必须与你们所有人一起度过七个半的辉煌赛季。
I learned so much about production and the business and my job and life, and I met so many amazing people who are still my friends to this day and a lot of the co-workers that I still work with to this day.
我学到了很多关于生产、商业、工作和生活的知识，我遇到了很多了不起的人，他们至今仍然是我的朋友，还有很多至今仍与我共事的同事。
And I just got to hang out with magical people and do an experience and see so many amazing things.
我只是和神奇的人一起出去玩，体验一下，看到很多神奇的事情。
And I just got to start all of it in season three.
我刚刚在第三季开始所有这一切。
And so really season three changed my life.
所以第三季确实改变了我的生活。
And it's always going to hold a special place in my heart because of that.
因此，它永远在我心中占有特殊的位置。
Love you.
爱你。
Kelly.
凯莉.
Oh my gosh, that's so nice to hear from Kelly.
天哪，听到凯利的消息真是太高兴了。
Kelly was with us from that moment until the end, worked in production, and she was in utter delight and array of sunshine all the time.
凯利从那一刻起一直和我们在一起，直到最后，她一直在制作中工作，她一直处于极度的快乐和阳光之中。
You could not all see ever seeing a scowl on Kelly's face.
你们不可能都在凯利的脸上看到过愁容。
No, all positivity, smiling and so.
不，一切都是积极的，微笑等等。
Yes, she was part of the fabric right away, right away became that.
是的，她立刻就成为了布料的一部分，立刻就变成了布料。
Kelly, you became that right away, and you were you were a heart and soul him.
凯利，你立刻就变成了那样，你就是他的全心全意。
You were the moment you started till the moment the show ended.
从你开始的那一刻直到演出结束的那一刻都是你。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
That's so nice to hear.
很高兴听到这个消息。
All right.
好的。
And now we've also got what we've got.
现在我们也得到了我们所得到的。
We've got letters.
我们有信。
We've got voice bells coming in.
我们有语音铃声进来。
Josh, you want to tell us all about that for our new listeners.
乔什，你想为我们的新听众讲述这一切。
And we've got our first letter of the season.
我们收到了本季的第一封信。
Sure.
当然。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, one of our favorite things on the show is hearing from you, hearing from fans, hearing from people who, how they discovered how I met your mother, what it has meant to them, how it's impacted their lives.
好吧，我们在节目中最喜欢的事情之一就是听到你的声音，听到粉丝的声音，听到人们的声音，他们是如何发现我是如何遇见你母亲的，这对他们意味着什么，这对他们的生活有何影响。
You wouldn't believe the beautiful synchronic stories we get to hear at such a treat, it's one of our favorite things about the show.
你不会相信我们在这样的盛宴上听到的美丽的同步故事，这是我们最喜欢的节目之一。
If you would like to share your story with us, either as a voice note or in a written letter, please go to how we made your mother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com, go to contact and it should be pretty clear from there how to do that.
如果您想以语音留言或书面形式与我们分享您的故事，请访问我们如何制作您的 mother.com、h-w-m-y-m.com、联系我们，从那里应该很清楚如何做到这一点。
But please let us know.
但请告诉我们。
We are always delighted to hear from you.
我们总是很高兴收到您的来信。
And today, we have a letter from Ava.
今天，我们收到了一封来自艾娃的信。
Hi, Josh Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什·克雷格和亚历克。
My name is Ava and I live in Northern California.
我叫艾娃，住在北加州。
I just wanted to let you know how much I'm enjoying the podcast.
我只是想让你知道我有多喜欢这个播客。
It truly feels like the gift that keeps on giving.
这真的感觉就像是不断赠送的礼物。
I first watched him in college and was immediately hooked after the first few episodes of season one.
我第一次看他是在大学里，第一季的前几集之后我就立刻被迷住了。
Old tech alert, I was watching the DVD box set because that's how it was done for you streaming.
老技术警报，我正在观看 DVD 盒装，因为这就是为您的流媒体制作的方式。
It has since become my comfort show.
从那时起，它就成了我的安慰秀。
I've watched it countless times and we even have a pet named Swarley.
我已经看过无数遍了，我们甚至还有一只名叫斯沃利的宠物。
Amazing.
惊人的。
I'm a public health nurse and I do home visits to support first time moms.
我是一名公共卫生护士，我会进行家访以支持新手妈妈。
Many of my clients are navigating financial instability, homelessness, and interpersonal violence, all while adjusting to life with a newborn.
我的许多客户都在应对财务不稳定、无家可归和人际暴力的问题，同时还要适应新生儿的生活。
As you can imagine, it can feel like the weight of the world is on my shoulders some days.
正如你可以想象的那样，有时我会感觉世界的重量都压在了我的肩上。
I'm so grateful I can listen to your podcast while driving between visits.
我很感激我可以在两次访问之间开车时听你的播客。
It brings lightness to my day and somehow always leaves me feeling a little more hopeful.
它给我的一天带来轻松，并且总是让我感觉更有希望。
The podcast has also introduced me to so many great things.
播客还向我介绍了很多很棒的事情。
I discovered Craig's debut novel through the show and immediately knew I had to read it.
我通过这部剧发现了克雷格的处女作，并立即知道我必须读它。
I even made 10 other people read it too as it was my book club pick.
我什至让其他 10 个人也读了这本书，因为它是我读书俱乐部的选择。
You're welcome.
不客气。
I love, I love Eva, Eva, Eva, whoever it is.
我爱，我爱伊娃，伊娃，伊娃，不管是谁。
Well, how we pronounce your name, we love you.
好吧，我们如何发音你的名字，我们爱你。
That's not how it happened by Craig.
克雷格的情况并非如此。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I connected deeply with the characters.
我与角色有着很深的联系。
My own daughter has health needs, and I was 12 when my older brother began dealing with serious health issues.
我自己的女儿有健康需求，当我哥哥开始处理严重的健康问题时，我才 12 岁。
He has since had two liver transplants and continues to face everything with more grace, hope, and humor than I could ever imagine.
此后，他接受了两次肝脏移植手术，并继续以比我想象的更多的优雅、希望和幽默来面对一切。
The podcast also introduced me to some phenomenal music.
播客还向我介绍了一些非凡的音乐。
I hadn't heard any of Josh's work before, but now I can't help but sing along to NYC and have been exploring more of his music.
我以前没有听过乔什的任何作品，但现在我情不自禁地跟着纽约一起唱歌，并一直在探索更多他的音乐。
I always knew him and featured great indie tracks, but I never fully appreciated them until now.
我一直都认识他，并推荐了很棒的独立曲目，但直到现在我才完全欣赏它们。
I've started to listen to playlists featuring songs from the show, and it makes me picture all the scenes that I'm instantly filled with joy.
我开始听节目中歌曲的播放列表，它让我想象出所有的场景，我立刻充满了喜悦。
Thank you for creating a show that continues to make me laugh and smile.
感谢您创作了一个继续让我开怀大笑的节目。
And for this podcast that adds so much joy to my daily life, I truly appreciate the company on my commutes and the brightness you bring to my days.
对于这个为我的日常生活增添如此多欢乐的播客，我真诚地感谢我通勤时的陪伴以及你为我的生活带来的光明。
Also, congratulations to Josh and Jordana on your first baby.
另外，祝贺乔什和乔丹娜有了第一个孩子。
I'm here for all your first time parent questions.
我在这里解答您第一次为父母提出的所有问题。
Lots of love.
满满的爱。
Take her up on it.
带她去吧。
She knows.
她知道。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
That was the sweetest letter.
那是最甜蜜的信。
The best.
最好的。
Thank you so much.
太感谢了。
Aren't you honored by like, how articulate, empathetic, kind, and intelligent, how much mother fans are.
多么能言善道，善解人意，善良又聪明，有多少妈妈迷，你不感到荣幸吗？
We get these messages that are just unbelievable.
我们收到这些令人难以置信的消息。
Yeah.
是的。
They're just one person honor, really.
他们只是一个人的荣誉，真的。
Very human.
非常人性化。
Human, very human, human, caring.
人性化，非常人性化，人性化，充满关怀。
You know, did you, have you seen that little like AI kind of meme that's going around of just all the himeum characters on their phones?
你知道吗，你有没有看到过类似人工智能的模因，它在手机上的所有 himeum 角色中传播？
Yeah.
是的。
Right?
正确的？
I'm saying it.
我说的是。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's, it's sad.
这是，这很悲伤。
Like it is sad.
好像很悲伤一样。
It's very sad.
这是非常悲伤的。
It makes me sad.
这让我很难过。
Yes, it does.
是的，确实如此。
Which I guess is the point.
我想这就是重点。
But I think, you know, Wendell Berry, this great philosopher, farmer poet, he said, there's going to come a time in the future when people are gonna have to choose if they wanna be humans or machines.
但我认为，温德尔·贝里，这位伟大的哲学家、农民诗人，他说，未来有一天，人们将不得不选择是想成为人类还是机器。
Yeah.
是的。
And I feel like how I met your mother is like pretty team human.
我觉得我和你母亲的相遇就像是一个非常团队合作的人。
It is team human.
这是团队人。
It's a team human show.
这是一场团队人类表演。
There's not a lot of tech.
没有太多技术。
there's just beer and laughter and relationships and quirky, interesting, fun characters.
只有啤酒、笑声、人际关系和古怪、有趣、有趣的角色。
And you can hear it back in these letters that these are human beings that felt like they were watching a very human show and it helped them reflect more deeply on their own human experience.
你可以从这些信件中听到，这些人感觉自己正在观看一场非常人性化的表演，这帮助他们更深入地反思自己的人类经历。
Yeah, yeah, it's exactly who you want to believe was watching and is watching our TV show.
是的，是的，这正是您想要相信的人正在观看并且正在观看我们的电视节目。
Yeah, and who we were making it for.
是的，以及我们为谁而做的。
You were making it for it.
你是为了它而努力的。
Like who's on the other end of the line.
就像电话那头的人是谁一样。
We hope it's Ava's.
我们希望这是艾娃的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think with all this time that has passed and all the ways we now can connect with fans, and some of it ironically is through technology, it's a complicated thing, right?
我认为随着时间的推移以及我们现在可以与粉丝联系的所有方式，其中一些具有讽刺意味的是通过技术，这是一件复杂的事情，对吗？
We're getting social media technology, we are getting some good things too, we're like, we're getting that message and it's just proof positive that the people we're putting our little messages in a bottle to, we're finding them.
我们正在获得社交媒体技术，我们也获得了一些好东西，我们就像，我们正在收到该信息，这只是积极的证据，证明我们将小信息放入瓶子中的人们，我们正在找到它们。
It was washing up on the right shores, our little messages and we're so grateful for that.
我们的小信息被冲上了正确的海岸，我们对此非常感激。
That's the best part to do when this is hearing from you guys, so keep them coming.
当收到你们的来信时，这是最好的部分，所以请让他们来。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一个点），我们的 Gen Z Masters（我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg）和副制作人 Katherine Grove（凯瑟琳·格罗夫）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，无论在哪里出售书籍，事情都不是这样发生的，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
out the make a difference tab at the top of our website.
出我们网站顶部的“有所作为”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。